hey guys Pete here today we're going to
do the recap and review for Twin Peaks
season 3 episode 7 this is your spoiler
warning there will be plenty of spoilers
past this point and it was an
action-packed episode so I'm going to
try to streamline the scene-by-scene a
little bit this time but don't forget
there will be a timestamp link in the
bottom in the description so you can
skip right over that if you want alright
so we start off with Gary Horn and he's
in the woods he appears to be lost he
looks scared and he calls his brother
Ben and tells him his car's been stolen
he doesn't know where he's at and he
thinks he's hi I don't want to go on
about this for too long because it is a
short little scene but it's interesting
that he's in the woods right because he
is I mean a lot of weird stuff has
happened in the woods outside of 20 so
curious as to what he's doing there at
this time could be important but also it
kind of reflects you know he's kind of
like dougie coupe right now in a way so
that's another thing I mean it is the
opening scene so it's kind of important
I think but we don't know why yet so I
won't ramble on about it next we get a
big payoff we get a lot of information
about a lot of stuff we've been thinking
about for a long time
the pages from the bathroom stall door
were from Laura Palmer secret diary it
was a retelling of the dream she had
with Annie when Annie told her to write
it down she did it's the good dales in
the lodge and he can't leave so I
mentioned this in the top moments video
but it's really crucial here that Hawk
got this stuff that he found this stuff
because he doesn't discredit it right
away he doesn't discredit the
supernatural aspect I mean he's been to
the entrance of the lodge twice now
which we really should talk about the
last time he was there but I don't have
time in this video but anyways there's
three pages from the diary we find out
there's one more that's missing we read
one side of two of them so there's more
info there that we haven't really got
into yet but hawk does a really good job
of telling Frank Truman who wasn't
around what was going on and tells him
the doc Hayward Cooper after he left but
he doesn't know if anybody else did now
they don't mention major breaks here and
I don't know if that's on purpose
what I mean maybe it's already probably
told them that the Cooper went to see
his father so maybe it's just implied
that they already know that I don't know
I don't know if that's important or not
I mean they should know that he
definitely did see Cooper before Cooper
left town but they don't mention him
another thing is is that they realized
that Leland probably put the pages in
the stall door since they refer the
one-page that they read refers to him
Hawk takes that to be true and he says
he must have put them there whenever he
was in for questioning in the Jacque
Renault murder
Frank does say that he's going to call
Harry harry s truman and get him up to
speed and see what he thinks and we you
know we leave this team with the idea
that a lot of stuff is now out in the
open next we see him calling see Frank
Truman call his brother Harry it's a
one-way conversation and that we can
hear what Frank saying but not what
Harry sang but it basically boils down
to he's not doing well he needs to get
rest Frank tells him he was going to
talk to him about some stuff but he
decides not to so we don't get any input
from Harry us at all about what Frank
just learned we do get a touching moment
between the brothers though whenever
Frank says Harry beat this thing
next we run into deputy Andy who is
investigating the hit and run he arrives
at the guy's house who owns the truck
and we find out right away it's not
Richard horn I believe this is Bill who
we'll talk about later
but it's kind of just a guess so I might
just be making that up anyways he tells
Andy that he wasn't driving Andy asked
him says he needs to know who it is that
was driving and they make an agreement
to meet at another location in a couple
hours he tells them a specific place to
meet and we find out it took 4:30 which
could be of note because that's what the
giant said to Cooper in the very
beginning it's a little bit odd here
that and he just leaves and doesn't
press the issue while he's there there
might be something going on we don't
know about what they might know each
other but one of the things that seems
pretty important at the end is as Andy's
walking back to his car we see another
car pass on the road so at least someone
saw that the police were at Bill's house
or whatever this guy's name is back at
the sheriff's office Frank called doc
Hayward he calls him one third and asked
if he knows about skype doc Hayward says
he uses it all the time gives him his
handle and they have a conversation
which was one of if not the biggest
moments of this entire episode Frank
asked him about agent Cooper he says he
remembers that Dale was acting weird
he took them to the hospital to check
him out while he was doing his rounds an
hour later he saw him leaving the ICU
fully dressed the doctor yelled out for
him but he didn't say anything he just
walked away when Frank asked why he
might have been in the ICU doc Hayward
says that he figured he was looking in
on Audrey who had just you know was in a
coma after what happened at the bank
like I already babbled on about this in
the other video but it's just really
good I just watched it again in it the
whole dog handler part just gives me
chills I'll talk a little bit more about
what Cooper might have been doing in the
ICU after we finished the scene by scene
in Buckhorn South Dakota
lieutenant Knox has arrived to check out
the prints from major Briggs he's
surprised to learn that it's not just
prints from a crime scene but it's
actually prints on a body that they have
in their morgue she checks it out and
realizes there's no head and that the
body is of a man in his late 40s who
died within the last five or six days
she goes and calls Colonel Davis right
away and explains the situation but it's
pretty confident that it is actually
Briggs his body but can't explain the
head or the age Colonel Davis said he's
going to make another call that other
call which I assume is the FBI since he
said that before and while they're
talking the man who I believe is the
same guy that we saw in the jail cell
when bill Hastings was there starts to
walk down the hall and it's really not
clear to me if she sees him or not like
we hear the electrical noise and we see
him walking up she looks that way and it
looks like she sees him but then she
takes off right away because she's in
the middle of something important so I
don't know I mean he doesn't seem like
the kind of guy that you see and then
not take a double take or something so
it's I don't know if she saw him or not
but she goes back in and tells the
police
that they should not let anybody else
see the body and that she thinks the
case will no longer be theirs as in the
FBI will be coming in we see the guy in
black cover you know covered with black
walked by again we hear the electrical
noise and there are some people out
there who think this is a different guy
who's covered in oil or so but I'm still
in the camp of it being the same person
I just think he looks a little bit
different walking around other people
think that it's a totally different
character all together we get a quirky
scene of Gordon whistling in his office
I read somewhere
it's Rammstein that he's whistling I
don't really know we see a corn on the
cob on his wall in the beginning of the
scene and then we also see the giant
mushroom cloud behind him Albert comes
in he tells them things didn't go well
with Diane basically that she said no
[ __ ] way they have a good back and
forth and then once Gordon says please
Albert agrees to accompany him to go
back and see her again they head over to
Diane's apartment where we see she's
entertaining a younger man I read that
that was Don Johnson's son but I didn't
verify it but she's still not happy to
see them at all
they tell her that Cooper is in federal
prison and she says good then eventually
she comes around Gordon is awesome at
the scene and Diane is you know Lord
darkness Diane is just fantastic I'll
talk more about that later
but he basically says you know you need
to this may require a change of attitude
on your part so she listens and they
tell her that they think something's
wrong they don't know what it is but
they need someone else to talk to Cooper
who knows him well and then tell them
what she thinks ultimately she agrees to
get straight on the plane to South
Dakota and we noticed that Diane not
only drinks but she seems to drink
around the clock and smoke cigarettes in
every one of her scenes even on the
plane she's still not on board and she
sort of sitting on her own and in the
back we see Gordon and Albert talking
and Tammy comes over to show them the
prints we see what she has discovered
earlier and that Albert confirms that
someone switched the prints and they had
to flip it over to make it
so yeah the prints aren't from actually
evil coupe at least not that one so if
there's been some doctoring that's
happened there when Timmy asks about
that Gordon gives a really cool
demonstration where he shows her that
the left ring finger is the spiritual
mound or the spiritual finger and that's
the one that was messed up he doesn't
give us any more info he just tells her
to think about that and then we see a
picture of evil coupe in what is
supposedly in Brazil this has been
mentioned that this is Al Capone's house
outside of Miami but that's really not
important to the story just an
interesting fact and as they're talking
you can see that Diane is really
thinking about something we don't know
what it is at this point but she has
real reservations of meeting with Cooper
again after getting reassurance that
she'll be in control and that she won't
have to stay longer than she wants to
and a quick [ __ ] you - Tammy which was
in the top moments video and was classic
Diane goes in and talks to evil - it's
the same setup that we saw earlier
whenever that you know behind the screen
in the classroom
she asks when the last time they saw
each other was basically evil coupe I
should say basically says that he thinks
Diane's upset with him she presses the
issue and eventually he said the last
time they saw each other was at her
house and we get the idea that something
that happened that it was probably after
evil coupe left the lodge and then left
Twin Peaks and it was traumatic at the
very least for Diane she says who are
you and then she leaves on the way out
Gordon makes a quick stop to say to the
warden thanks for everything and make
sure that he tells the warden to hold
him until they hear from outside Diane
is a wreck she's really upset she has a
heart-to-heart with Gordon saying that
it was not anything about his physical
appearance at the time that's passed but
there was something missing in this guy
something in his heart and it was not
the Dale Cooper that she knew Gordon
says he understands and that's good
enough for him and also asked about the
last night that they spent together and
she says that they
have a talk then she has a drink and
like I said she's a message than a bad
thing whatever happened we can
definitely speculate but we don't know
for sure as they're escorting him back
to his cell
evil cook tells the CEO that he needs to
talk to the warden's office and to tell
him that it's about a strawberry I can
join please to get a shot in the
mountains and we hear the stop the music
the ominous music in the background a
little bit we see that Amy's waiting to
meet the truck owner who hasn't shown we
see a quick shot of his house the doors
open and we hear a little bit of the
electrical noise in the background and
then we cut back to Andy who checks his
Rolex just kind of weird but I won't get
into that here and we see that he's you
know good half an hour and five minutes
late so that Andy gives up and he takes
off stuck in the warden's office evil
coupe is brought in and shackled to the
chair the warden thinks he has the upper
hand at first tells him that the cameras
are often they can speak freely but it
totally gets turned around and I'm not
going to even pretend I understand what
they're talking about here but he brings
up the dog leg because there's three
more of those and that they went out
with the information that he's thinking
about to people that he doesn't want
coming around if they find out something
happens to him so he has him again he
goes back against the wall but I don't
know what all that means
either way coop tells him he wants a car
he wants a gun he says a friend in the
glove box I assume that's a gun and
Raymond row which is Ray and that they
want to leave at one o'clock tonight
smooth and easy and the warden has no
choice but to let him go back at
Dougie's office we see that Jani E is
outside waiting and that inside ducky
coop has not stopped drawing he's
drawing something that doesn't fit on
the page and for at this point so we're
scratching it into the thing on his desk
Anthony or Tony is there he's asking why
Dougie coop is not talking to him and he
wants to know what he went into
Bushnell's office with and at the same
time the secretary comes to tell him
that there are police there and
imperative her he has her bring them in
outside Jani got fed up and so she
marches her way inside and I say March
because that's what she does
three detectives come in Dougie's
officers as the jain EEE at the same
time and bushnell Mullins as well we
find out that they found the car that
there were three fatalities Janie
II is awesome as usual and kind of
controlling the conversation and yeah I
mean it this is kind of the opposite of
all the other Doug you seen so far we
find out a bunch of stuff in a short
period of time and since these other
people are there he his lack of anything
isn't really that big of an issue the
police now think that you know the car
was stolen by these guys and then it
blew up so it kind of gets them off the
hook at least a little bit and we find
out they wanted to come in and answer
some questions and that Bushnell also
has some questions about those files but
everyone's content and waiting til
tomorrow on the way downstairs Janie
gives him a rundown of what happened
with the payoff no michi ike the spike
coming through the crowd with a gun
pointed straight at dougie - he reacts
right away as an instinctual coupe like
super dougie coupe or whatever you want
to say here grabs the gun grabs this
hands Janie EE starts to attack him from
behind like the spike is no match for
them but then you see an image of the
arm show up in front of dougie coupe and
he tells him to squeeze his hand off so
W kid continues to squeeze until we see
that there's a big piece of flesh from
his arm left behind on the gun like the
spike Wiggles free and escapes but of
course the police show up news crews and
it's a big deal see the newscasters
interviewing a few of the people who
were witnesses they're singing dougie
Jones's praises even though they're
talking about dougie coupe and the
little girl says he smelled funny which
is something that might be of note but
you know my favorite part was the woman
saying that he moved the dougie moves
like a cobra and Janie's explanation to
the police now it makes you wonder if
they interviewed
dougie coupe or if they would at least
show his picture on the news this could
be important later as well but we don't
find that out for sure we do see the
police bagging
the big piece of flesh off of like the
spikes hand oh we can sort of drawn-out
scene where then is in his office after
hours with Beverly the assistant that we
met way back in part one when I first
watched I didn't know if there was
actually a sound or FF Everly was crazy
but when you watch there is it's almost
like music but on second watch I
realized that they can actually hear
what we hear so there is a hum but we're
really not sure what it is it's not
clear even by the end well they're
moving from side to side
Beverly finds the key and gives it to
Ben he realizes that it's old because
they've had cards for 20 years and that
it is from the room of agent Cooper
where he was shot we figure out that
Beverley isn't from Twin Peaks because
she has no idea who Laura Palmer is he
tells her it's a very long story and we
see that there's some sexual tension in
between them eventually he breaks it off
and then we see this crazy pan at the
end where the camera goes into the wood
paneling I mentioned this in the moments
video the top moments video and it could
be related to the sound or it could be
related to Josie I'm leaning more
towards the sound but let me know what
you guys think about that back at her
house we can see that
Beverly's husband Tom is quite sick I'm
not an expert in these things but since
he has no hair I think he probably has
cancer it's a heated exchange he is
suspicious of why she wasn't there
she's upset because she has to go back
to work and I don't really know how this
ties in to anything else at this point
we don't know who tom is as far as I can
think of and yeah I have a feeling it's
going to be important later but I don't
know what to take away from this except
for this is her situation at OU can we
get a really long and memorable theme of
jean-michele Renault behind the bar
while someone is sweeping this is at the
Roadhouse of course for about 2 plus
minutes we see the guy sweeping and we
listen to green onions by Booker T and
the MGS and despite the fact that I
really enjoy that song I'll tell you why
I like this scene it's certainly out of
place in a fast moving
episode but what I like about it is that
you know we're sitting there and the
whole time I'm on the edge of my seat
watching someone sweet it's just I'm
trained to think that something must be
going to happen and so it's interesting
because nothing really ever does until
the phone rings I know a lot of people
complain about this but I think it's
kind of great in the way that it is
presented of course if there were too
many of these things that would get old
but in this one instance I'm kind of
digging it when the phone rings we learn
a couple things we learned that John
Michell is into some things like jock
was find out that he's met two girls
straight-a students which he says are
[ __ ] straight-a [ __ ] to someone that
they were 15 and that that guy owes him
for two we also find out that the
Renault have owned the Roadhouse for 57
years and that hit this has nothing to
do with the Roadhouse so I'm not 100%
sure what to make out of this but I'd be
glad to hear what you guys think in the
comments is this just a callback to what
jock used to do with Laura or is this
something that we need to keep an eye on
at the prison ray and evil coop are
released without any incident as the
warden looks on all we know is that he
gets us gets his rental car he tells
ready to drive and he gets his phone
back but he's on the loose and we go
back to Twin Peaks where we get some
shots of the woods with some strange
sounds doesn't really tie anything
together but it's definitely eerie and
then we get a shot of the inside of the
Double R it looks like a normal
nightmare Shelley's behind the counter
serving coffee
Heidi's off to the left we see normal
working at her loose and then we see a
guy run up come inside he yells has
anybody seen bill no one answers and he
leaves then we get some music and the
end credits roll now there's a lot going
on in this little scene and I will touch
on that a little bit here and then a
little bit more in the 10 things you
might have missed video that will follow
right after that but for now we're going
to wrap this up and get into the
discussion all right this is a great
episode
if you skip through the scene-by-scene
and welcome to the video there's so much
to talk about here is almost
seem right to have this after the
scene-by-scene but I'm gonna do my best
to talk about some different things here
first off the big bombshell is Lauren's
diary pages there's a little bit of
continuity error stuff going on but I'm
not going to really I'm just going to
look at it for what it is right now it's
big that people are aware that something
happened to Dale after he returned from
the lodge how this is going to play
going forward is pretty up in the air I
mean there's several things happening
all at the same time that might bring
the real Cooper onto the radar the key
has arrived because the sound thing and
the sexual tension and everything else
was going on in that extended scene with
EE and then he didn't really get into it
but it would be hard to believe that he
doesn't go back to that idea that that
key came also because of the incident
with Ike to spike there's a distinct
possibility that dougie Jones may end up
on television and that could lead
somewhere as well as far as the pages
the most important thing I think is that
they know that there's something going
on with Cooper after he left but also I
mean it's good to know that leyland the
whole thing kind of makes sense to
everyone
now the other pages we didn't see is
there important stuff I don't know but I
do think that there's definitely
something important with the one page
that isn't there I have no idea where
that's at but I mean it was a pretty
specific how they explained that four
pages were unaccounted for and that this
was only three so those would be the
only three that Leland had on him when
he went to the police station
of course the Diane stuff was amazing
there's a definite implication that
something happened between her and
Cooper before he went into hiding and
that would definitely be the evil Cooper
based on what we've seen and I think it
you know I don't know what everyone else
thinks about dying because I haven't
read a lot about things this week but
this is not how I expected Diane I
expected her to be the female version of
Cooper and at this point she's pretty
much the opposite so I'd be interested
to hear what your thoughts were if this
is how you envision her or not I mean I
got the idea that they had a deep
connection through work because she kind
of got Cooper because she was the same
sort of way now is she like how she is
like drunk all the time
the
of what happened with her an evil Cooper
I don't know for sure but I think
there's an implication that might be the
case the Jerry Horne thing I think it's
important that we remember that he was
in the woods that could be important I
don't know if it is but everyone who's
disappeared
has disappeared in the woods near pink
Twin Peaks and he's just out there
lurking around in there as far as we can
tell the warden thing is a little bit
confusing like I said when we talked
about that theme I was definitely not
expecting him to say the dog leg or that
dog has four legs and on and on I mean
it was hilarious but there's what the
hell is he talking about
who is mr. strawberry and why would he
send three dog legs to different people
so the information got out as an
insurance plan like I don't get it but
it's it's great I like that I don't get
it
the Andy thing I mean yeah it seems a
little odd that he let that guy go and
set the plan to see him later obviously
hearing the electrical noises outside
the house while he's waiting gives us a
pretty good idea that that guy's not
around anymore is that bill I don't know
for sure I said I don't know because it
doesn't there is nobody named bill in
the credits there's a guy who's marked
farmer that could be this guy but it's
just not clear you know I mentioned at
the end the guy who comes in there was
confusion because in the subtitles it
said that it was him saying has anybody
seen thing according to the show's
executive producer that was a mistake
that is actually Bing who came who's
played by David Lynch's son Riley and he
was looking for bill so yeah there's a
bunch of stuff there when you look at
the shots they aren't the same people
whenever it cuts back from normal you
know Heidi's in a different place why
would there be a time jump right there
why did they show the woods right before
that I mean there's a lot to speculate
there and I want to hear what you guys
have to say about that for sure thing
doc Hayward and the mention of Cooper
going to the ICU there is one other
possibility I mean a lot of people are
thinking that it means that this theory
that evil coupe impregnated Audrey while
she was in her coat
is obviously true but there is another
thing as we know Annie was in the
hospital and the missing pieces we saw
that the nurse took the ring from Earth
but evil could have been looking for
that as well he could have taken it from
Annie he could have taken it from the
nurse if the you know if we're supposed
to accept that the missing piece is
saying is canon so yeah it's not a
confirmation about the Audrey thing it
could be a red herring or it could be
something we need to learn more about so
yeah this video is getting super long
already so I'm going to have to wrap it
up but I think that one of the big
things here the sort of a revelation of
a fast-moving episode with a lot of
stuff coming to light that we had been
speculating about is that this is
starting to make sense a little bit to
me I'm not going to say that I
understand Frost & Lynch's whole
strategy or anything like that I'm not
that arrogant but in the sense it's
starting to make more sense in the whole
idea of Athena in the 18 hour movie what
was confusing about this in the
beginning was is that yeah it's long and
it's a movie by Cooper wasn't making a
lot of progress and that was frustrating
a lot of people what I'm starting to
understand a little bit better now is
that it's a bunch of stories and they
move at different paces this isn't
necessarily the story of agent Cooper
alone do you see what I'm saying like
yes it is about his journey back to his
old self but in the way that they're
setting things up different parts of the
story move at different speeds and
different episodes address different
things so I'm still pretty much on board
I still pretty much like everything I
like how we got a lot of payoffs here
and I think that it's going to continue
to move in that direction a lot of stuff
is happening it's taking a lot of
episodes to show us but of not that much
time has passed in the reality of the
show's timeframe so I'm interested I
want to know what you guys think
obviously I'll be doing a Q&A attempting
that you might have missed video I have
a couple of theory videos I've been
wanting to do and I'm going to try to
squeeze them in there so please like the
video please check back soon subscribe
to my channel so you won't miss any of
the Twin Peaks videos any questions you
have put them in the comments let me
know what you're thinking let me know
what you want to know about and thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon